I'm just getting back from the Samsung
Galaxy unpacked event and can I just
start this video off by saying that
cloud pink color in the s20 is so
beautiful I actually did fall off my
chair with excitement at the event
obviously maybe for colors pink so when
I saw that that was announced normally I
do go for the higher end models of
phones and this pink is only available
in the s20 model so my dreams were
slightly crushed but it's okay I think
that I'm just going to have to deal with
it so one of the things that a lot of
people were hinting at and speculating
online was that there was going to be an
announcement of another foldable flip
type phone from Samsung Samsung
surprised everybody by launching a
commercial at the Oscars of this I'm
surprised how high-quality this feels
because a lot of times flip phones like
this you think it's gonna feel kind of
like plasticy this is actually an
ultra-thin class it comes in three
different colors I have a full video of
this on my channel already but this
video is kind of an overview of the flip
and the rest of the s20 phones that were
launched here unpacked so now onto
phones that don't flip or fold so this
is a be a samsung galaxy s 20 ultra this
is the S 20 plus and Jenna over there
has the s 20 are you ready to do a flip
yeah there it is oh my gosh a lot of
companies Samsung included have really
been stressing that 5g is the future in
2020 it's going to become mainstream not
sure if a hundred percent agree that 5g
is going to be mainstream in 2020 I
think that we're on our way there
it'll be mainstream when my parents or
my grandmother rush out to get a 5g
phone that's when we know it's
mainstream but what I love that Samsung
is doing is they are further pushing
this 5g agenda forward by making all
three of these phones 5g enabled all
three also have 120 Hertz displays a
64-bit 2.7 gigahertz octa-core processor
and all new camera system they also all
record 8k video they have wireless
charging and also the power share which
if you've seen that before you can
basically charge another phone using
another phone it's magic all three each
at least have 12 keys of RAM and you can
expand the internal storage up to one
terabyte using a microSD card the s20
ultra obviously has some upgrades over
the other two phones so we're
go through and compare all three phones
but I want to start with the s20 ultra
so that we can kind of work our way down
so you can compare to see what each
phone has in comparison to the other the
top-of-the-line Samsung Galaxy S 20
ultra it comes in two colors
a cosmic gray and a cosmic black can't
decide if I were the gray or the black I
want the pink but it's not an option so
let me know in the comments below which
color you think I should get I kind of
think I like the gray but I also kind of
like the black a lot it has a six point
nine inch 120 Hertz AMOLED display it
has a quad camera which features a 10
megapixel front selfie camera 12
megapixel ultra wide 108 megapixel
wide-angle could we just stop for a
moment in just a hundred and eight
megapixels just wanted to reiterate yes
that is correct
it has a 48 megapixel telephoto lens and
depth vision which allows better
focusing and depth sensing hybrid optic
zoom of de 10x and super resolution zoom
up to a hundred x we just pause for just
another second and yes I did say a
hundred X assume to be able to get 100 X
zoom on a phone I think is pretty
impressive we saw a bunch of different
demo photos and I did get a chance to
check it out for myself
continuing on the specs of the ultra 8k
video recording of course that's across
all three phones you can choose from 12
or 16 gigs of ram 128 or 512 internal
storage a five thousand milliamp battery
all with a starting price of 13.9 next
up we have our middle of the line this
is the samsung galaxy s 20 plus this
comes in a cosmic grey cloud blue and
cosmic black and still no pink I have a
very big frown like watch this it has a
six point seven inch AMOLED 120 Hertz
display it almost has the quad camera
set up very similar to the s20 ultra
with a 12 megapixel ultra wide camera 12
megapixel wide-angle sixty four
megapixel telephoto also with depth
vision 3x optical and 30x super
resolution zoom 8k video 12 gigs of ram
128 or 512 gigs of storage again
expandable to one terabyte with a micro
SD card
4,500 million battery and a starting
price at
99 and now for the s20 which is their
lower end model the starting price for
this one is $9.99 but this one comes in
the cloud pink I mean can we just we
need to take a minute to appreciate this
color I'm showing you photos I'm showing
you videos but nothing really does it
justice until you hold it in your hand
and you see it with your very own two
eyes my heart melted right there in San
Francisco isn't there a song about
leaving your heart at New York I don't
know either way I think I left my heart
in San Francisco with the cloud pink s20
also available in the cloud blue in the
cosmic ray just in case pink isn't your
color it's fine it's okay I'm not
judging I see really judging much like
the Internet
it only has a triple camera setup only
but this is 2020 and we're saying oh it
only has a triple camera setup do we
ever really think that we would have
more than three cameras on a cell phone
at any given time back in the day when
we first started using cell phones no it
really was not something that I ever
thought of but the future is here this
model is lacking the depth vision camera
that's available on the higher-end
models it still has the 10 megapixel
selfie camera 12 megapixel ultra wide 12
megapixel wide-angle and sixty four
megapixel telephoto it does do 8k video
it is a smaller 6.2 inch AMOLED display
like I mentioned before all three
devices have 120 Hertz capabilities
which is pretty impressive for them to
put that across their entire lines so
this really does mean the Samsung is
saying listen 120 yards display and 5g
it's here and we are here for it or
you're here for it because we're making
it for you there's a four thousand
milliamp battery 12 gigs of RAM and 128
gigs of internal storage also expandable
to one terabytes with a micro SD card if
you haven't figured that out by now one
of the things that I'm really excited
though is the fact of this phone shoots
8k video and not just the higher end all
three of these phones are incredible so
no matter which one you bet you're still
getting a lot of the main features like
8k recording on a cell phone really
isn't necessary no or do I love it yes
most televisions can't even support the
fact that this is a
one of the things that is pretty cool is
they do have an onboard video editor so
you're able to scale down your videos
you don't actually have to export it at
8k you can scale up to 4k 1080 whatever
you want it to be it's really cool about
shooting in 8k is you can also take a
still from the video so you can produce
a 33 megapixel photo from your 8k video
and one of the things that I do love
about what I'm shooting at Kay is you're
able to take really great high-quality
screenshots from the content that you've
shot because you're shooting in such a
high resolution you have so much to work
with they also updated the stabilization
for these new phones and one of the
things and this isn't just common to the
Samsung phones but this isn't a lot of
cameras in general a lot of times it
will only adjust stabilization if you're
moving your camera kind of up and down
but if it moves to the side it doesn't
really stabilize that well if you're
moving things from side to side that
side to side motion tends to not be
stabilized so that is something that was
upgraded in these phones not only will
it stabilize things that are going with
like this but will go like this which
means if you're going like this your
footage is gonna be extra stable I think
that was a really good demo I'm here all
day I also really love the night
hyperlapse feature this is something
that I cannot wait to try out this new
camera system also allows for better
low-light imaging with a larger sensor
it'll be doubling the amount of images
that are being processed to get you the
best photos without a lot of lights they
also have this new multi ISO composition
so it takes a series of photos with
variable ISO and it'll merge them all
together to get you the best shot the
new camera system also allows for better
low-light imaging with a larger sensor
it'll double the amount of images being
processed to get you the best photos
without a lot of light single take is
really cool so with one press of the
shutter it will take a 10 second video
and then kind of package you some
content out of that it'll give you a
series of photos a boomerang like video
and you'll be able to choose what you
want from that 10 seconds so if
something is happening you won't miss
the moment it'll package you up a ton of
stuff that you can then share out to the
internet because that's what we all do I
love what they make gaming a focus as
well because we have such incredible
high power
vices in the palm of our hands so to be
able to take that and just push it a
little bit further they doubled the
pressure sensitivity on the screens so
for gaming this is gonna be amazing
because you can be more accurate and
quicker in your movements they also
announced that force that will be
available on your freaking phone can you
believe this I love this game I love
this game so much did you guys play the
force of Lego DLC on Xbox because if you
didn't you definitely should if you also
we're talking about this really cool
feature that you can load depending upon
your phone at least three apps into your
phone's RAM so you won't have to worry
about any startup time it'll just be
pre-loaded and you click and open no
loading time I think that's gonna be
pretty huge for gaming so I feel like a
lot of apps really are that you just
like Twitter don't think it's gonna take
that long to load baby things like
Lightroom or different games that's
really what that's for another thing for
gaming 120 Hertz display looks
incredible so I'm just really happy that
they did put this on all three of the
models not to try to convince you to buy
the more expensive one so that you can
have the faster display it's on all
three and that pink if we talked about
the pink phone Oh mmm it looks so good
while I look forward to checking out
these phones more in depth if there's
anything that you would like to know or
have any other questions or would like
to see in a future video leave those all
in the comments below I had a really
great time at the unpacked event it's
always so good to see so many of my tech
friends I feel like we all just get to
hang out at Tech offense but it's always
great to see everybody make sure you
guys subscribe so you don't miss any of
the videos that I'll be posting about
these phones be sure to like the video
hit the bell I already told you to
subscribe and I think that's all of my
homework tasks for you if you haven't
already I see you later bye
[Music]